they rope Mexicans down there with a
horse and a whip that's what they do
that's why they're a state they're not a
state because Elon Musk moved Tesla to
Texas they're not a state because my
good friend Joe Rogan has a comedy club
there they are a state because when when
when things get going they send out
people on Horseback to whip the Mexican
and some of them are
Mexican some there are more Latinos in
then there are whites there's a lot of
Latino cow Mexican Cowboys
wrangling other types of Latinos
Mexicans and Central Americans and it
that is not my business nor should it be
yours it seems like it's it's a it's a
cultural thing that isn't you know it
looks it looks on the outside it doesn't
look great the itics are bad because no
one respects the Western way of life
anymore you understand like no one
respects the you know what I mean the
shoe leather kind of just you know like
getting the boots on getting on the
horse people don't rope and ride the way
they used to people don't but these are
people that are enforcing the law in the
way it has been enforc
forever whipping and
wrangling
and this is what's going on in Texas you
have people out
there because the people are coming in
illegally and they are breaking a law
listen whether you like it or not that's
what's happening and then the sheriff's
in Texas or the border patrol I don't
know who these people are I don't know
who it is Walker Texas Ranger I don't
know but they're they're Rangers these
are real live Texas law enforcement and
they're on
horseback and they're and they're doing
what they do mhm and it looks
terrible to people that are living like
people in New York City they read the
New York Times They open it they I oh my
do you see what they're doing in
Texas they're whipping the Mexicans in
Texas that're coming over the board but
this is just the way that they they
number one they operate on horseback M
they
do now the thing that they're using that
um what is it it's say what is it what
are they doing there with that it's a
whip isn't it but is it isn't it doesn't
it serve another purpose as
well I
heard this is what they're saying right
now get some of these photos up because
it doesn't look great I think they're
lassoing the migrant I don't think
they're whipping them they're doing a
lasso which is not easy that is a
difficult thing to do they're on
Horseback now remember the migrants are
not just waiting to be lassoed they're
running they're running around and you
are on
Horseback with the lasso and it's got to
be big because M much like a cartoon you
are lassoing lots of people it's not
just one person occasionally you lasso
one person you or there's maybe a little
baby goes you little lasso get them you
know get a little toddler runs away from
the group you go boom and that's easier
but if you're GNA do a big lasso you
know it's like
um it's not easy it's not easy it's
difficult
and this is their
culture what is this the Rio Grand the
people coming out of the Rio Grand uh
yes these are and these are they were
using the Reigns The reigns of the horse
yes as they were they're let loosening
them out and then I guess and then
whipping the migrant that's what it
looked like yeah but they're saying that
they weren't whipping the mark but
listen how else and I'm not saying that
we should whip
people
but there's got to be some enforcement
of the
border and it is
Texas you get what I mean
yeah I don't know what they can do
they're on a horse they could pull out a
gun and shoot the people no one would
like that no one's going to be happy
with that YouTube's not even happy I
just said it I guarantee you they're not
even happy with that these freaks in
Venice aren't even happy with that that
I said it but I'm not but what would
they do they're on a horse what are they
going to do if the people are coming
now there's people that go you you must
welcome like the Humane thing to do and
there's an argument about to do this a
Humane thing to do with say come welcome
here you are you this is your new
home now the problem with that is that
they don't have the resources to do that
all of these states they don't and the
federal government has made a mess of
providing resources for these people
when they come here in New York City
they're sitting on the street the mayor
of New York's like we we don't have the
room the space the money we don't have
the
resources so I know everybody wants to
say that like these yeah dozens of
migrants are sleeping at Logan Airport
in
Boston there there isn't there aren't
resources to deal with this crisis right
now and
obviously these are human beings this is
you know this is a this is a human
tragedy they're not like political
pawns we obviously are funny about the
whole situation that's what we do but
they are human being
but that being
said there has to be
some
process by which people come into this
country this is the reason Trump won his
first election this is the reason he
might win his second election